it's my favorite macbook pro i've ever
used from apple and i even was using
them from the power book era
way back when when they were black
stealthy black bring it back apple
black is back
f1 max
let's make that happen what's going on
guys i am back with my third and final
video i won't say final because you
never know what'll come up but then my
final video for the time being
with the m1 max macbook pro 16 inch i
did a first impressions i did a
comparison against the 12th gen intel
processor where this just kicks a major
ass and now i'm going to give you my
final thoughts on this machine i've been
using it for the past couple months and
i'm just going to call it the beast if
you want a cliffnotes version of this
review and you don't have time to watch
this video i hope you do but i mean if
you don't have time
this is
the best content creators laptop pc for
the price or computer
money can buy right now that's my
personal opinion you may or may not
agree with me but based on my usage
video editing photography content
creation just media playback daily usage
it doesn't get much better than this
so that is my clip notes version of the
review i'll touch on some of the
highlights i've talked about in other
videos we'll put a link to that you can
check that out but
for right now
let's dig in a little bit deeper on the
m1 max macbook pro the design apple has
sort of regressed a little bit in design
it's a little bit thicker it's bigger
has more ports has an sd card slot into
it magsafe is back so you get that
magnetic latch locked to it when you're
charging it but i like to also charge by
a usbc as well it's all there so you
could say apple's
you know taken some feedback they've
listened to the users of these laptops
and said hey we want more than just a
few ports we don't care about thinness
we want power we want something that is
efficient that can actually do the work
that we need to especially in 3d
rendering ak video you know if you're
using after effects or motion you're
creating content that
demands power you need a laptop that can
handle it that's where this m1 max comes
into play and it does it beautifully the
keyboard is fantastic on it it's the
trackpad is large it's massive it feels
great so easy to use this retina xdr
display
is a thing of epping beauty can i say
that online can i say that exactly
catholic beauty honestly i have not seen
a laptop display as beautiful as this
obviously apple has a display that six
grand usd that is probably equivalent or
better but outside of that this is
the creme de la creme it is so beautiful
to use as a matter of fact when i use
this at home sometimes i actually have
to hook it up to an external display
which is a beautiful display in its own
right but this is so nice
it doesn't compare
so
either i buy that six thousand dollar
apple display
or i just end up using the 16 inch
display because it really is that great
colors are accurate everything is so
rich and so
it just looks great when you're editing
the speaker systems in this laptop is
fantastic as well now the 16-inch
macbook pro a couple of years ago the
intel variant the speakers on that were
really really good it's improved with
this slightly there is a difference
you're going to notice it but it sounds
fantastic but of course
with a machine like this you probably
are not going to be using the speakers
on your laptop right your gut speakers
already at home it's on your desk you're
going to plug it in it's going to sound
even better but if you're on the go in a
hotel or if you're out on location
somewhere and you need access to
speakers these will do the jobs even the
microphones inside of this also work
really well if you want to do your zoom
calls your microsoft teams facetime this
will work really good with that let's
talk a little about the specs inside of
this bad boy we've got as i mentioned
the m1 max is the 10 core cpu 32 core
gpu 64 gigabytes of ram two terabytes of
storage inside of this beast this is
almost maxed out this would be the
optimal configuration for my wants and
needs
if budget wasn't an issue but of course
this laptop does come in at a you know a
pretty significant price point with this
setup
again this is meant for really
professional content creators or those
who want the best laptop money can buy
pretty much right now and it's going to
last you for a few years now a lot of
people say what about the m1 pro right
the monk pro is fantastic it will do the
job for you as well but the m1 max
if you want an investment
that's going to take you into
2023 maybe even 2024
i would spring for this
the mac pro or the m1 pro i think good
for a couple years as well but the max
is just that bit better if you need this
kind of power
this is the laptop to pick up how do i
use this for the most part i've used a
lot of photoshop i use a lot of
lightroom and i use final cut i've
dabbled with premiere pro a little bit
you know when we did our comparison
because uh zacky likes premiere pro he's
still you know he's on a pc
forgive him he'll get there he'll get
there
but
i use final cut because of the
efficiency and how great it is with pro
res uh and how fast it is so
i have really thoroughly enjoyed using
final cut on this even 8k no issues at
all but primarily i shoot in 4k and this
thing just eats up 4k for a snack it's
nothing to it you know and i'm dropping
various different layers on that you
know different timelines pictures
photographs music everything in there
and it works great no issues i have no
problems with this um photoshop as well
has been great with it
uh lightroom and i'm shooting what the
gfx100s images 100 megapixels about 200
megabytes an image eats it up no issues
at all the only program i found so far
that has been a little bit taxing on
this and is because of the usage of
memory is luminar ai luminar ai if you
can if you have it open and you're using
it along with photoshop or lightroom you
maybe get a low memory warning and has
nothing to do with actually the usage of
the memory inside the computer it's
because of the way that luminar doesn't
really maximize the m1 chipset and the
efficiency of the ram so you get some of
these issues so to overcome that you
just have to shut down lightroom or
photoshop when you're using luminar and
you shouldn't have an issue with it but
it's something that i've come across so
keep that in mind if you are luminar
user like myself because i like uluminar
sometimes it's great as a plugin for
photoshop at the same time it really
does some there's really some nice
editing features inside of it uh outside
of that though i mean day to day usage
of course browsing the web youtube
videos and all that kind of stuff but
when i
need that kind of content creation i
need that great battery life
this is the go-to for me and the great
thing about this laptop is i don't need
to have it plugged in to maximize the
power out of it now we talked about this
uh when we did our 8k rendering um
versus battle versus the 12th generation
intel chipset we were doing the battle
with this unplugged the entire time and
the power as apple claimed is the same
as it is plugged in and we could attest
to that it worked beautifully and
brilliantly again when you're using pro
applications the battery life will drain
faster than if you're just browsing the
web or using microsoft word or pages or
powerpoint for that matter but that's
like any other laptop out there so
that's just something to keep in mind
the latest os from apple is fantastic
the updates these companies are putting
out through adobe
through capture one they're continually
improving their software to maximize
this m1 chipset and how it's designed to
utilize ram and storage and everything
else so you're going to see a better
efficiency and better power and just
better overall performance in the months
to come it's great so far and it's going
to continue to get even better and i've
seen that over the last couple months
i've been using it so if there was any
complaints i had on this laptop it would
be the amount of usbc thunderbolt 4
ports on this now there's only three you
have an hdmi port you have a sd card
slot there now which is great mic input
jack but only three usbc thunderbolt 4
ports now why couldn't they give it
four or six
nothing it doesn't all have to be
thunderbolt 4 it could just be usbc you
know it's give us something because
when you put this on your desk and it's
gonna so it is a desktop replacement in
a lot of ways you're going to want to
hook a lot of different things on it i
mean i use external sd drives you know
thunderbolt 3 drives right that's a port
i use my zoom f6 that's a port so if i
was to put a cf express card reader in
there type a or type b
i need ports
so that's already eaten up
and then anything else
i'm out of luck i got to get an adapter
for this and for a laptop that costs
this much apple and there's enough room
on the side of it now because it's
thicker
could have afforded more ports for this
i think in my personal opinion maybe the
engineers
whatever maybe there's a person in
charge of ports at apple that i don't
know
doesn't like them maybe they should hire
somebody that likes ports because it
needs a little bit more ports for a pro
machine that's my personal take hdmi is
great but honestly speaking
i mean some people will use hdmi i'm not
going to say they're not but i don't
think this this was a necessity as much
as a us another usb or two usb-c ports
that's just me
besides that though
i love it i love it it's a beautiful
machine it is pricey it is a heavy
investment i'm not going to kid you on
that and it's not going to be for
everyone out there but for those who
have the means or has the budget from
your company
to afford these
you are going to be more than happy with
what you get out of this i mean
everybody else is saying the same thing
online i'm just sort of repeating the
same thing but this is really what this
machine is all about anyway i've said a
lot about this machine thus far as you
can tell i like it i've done three
videos on it so obviously i like it
now here's a message from our sponsor
here geek culture audio is a huge part
of our daily lives both work and play so
what's our choice of headphones well
meet the logitech g435 lightspeed
wireless gaming headset it lets you
listen to all the rich sounds from your
music videos and games across pc console
and mobile while sporting some popping
vibrant colors not only that it weighs
just 165 grams which means sometimes
you'll even forget that you're wearing
it with a robust battery life of 18
hours you can enjoy your gaming sessions
for prolonged periods of time for more
details head over to logitechg.com
all right thank you so much logitech for
the sponsorship and support and helping
us keep the lights on here at geek
culture we appreciate it anyway final
thoughts on this laptop if you haven't
figured it out already throughout this
10 minutes of the review i love it it's
my favorite macbook pro i've ever used
from apple and i even was using them
from the power book era
way back when when they were black
actually like black actually this
wouldn't be bad in black you know to
come to think about maybe that they
could improve that just not just silver
but black
stealthy black bring it back apple black
is back 2022 macbook pro i'll do the
voiceover for you
right zach you can sweeten that up and
post
black is back
f1 max
let's make that happen anyway besides
that i love it honestly it's a great
laptop and for any of you that can
afford it pick it up you will thoroughly
enjoy that's it with that guys follow us
on facebook subscribe to us on youtube
like this video helps out our channel a
lot and it keeps people like logitech
wanting to sponsor our videos as well
which we appreciate and i'll see you
soon bye
[Music]
you